こんにちは実は超ビビリはじめしゃちょー
ですはい今どこにいるかというとはじめ
しゃちょーの3億円のお家にいるんです
けども実は今年に入ってからですね
去年ぐらいからかな去年の年末ぐらいから
実は3億円のおうちかなり大改造工事とし
ておりましてこれから動画で色々発表して
いくと思うんですけどもかなり
[音楽]
寒気のうち
すごいことになってきましたよこれ
止まるかな
プラス1億行っちゃうかそんな3億円大
改造中の第1弾ですかね今回はその第1弾
の動画になりますただ結構竿系のおうちの
こう進化の動画がこれから増えると思う
楽しみにしててくださいなんか世界の情勢
とかも結構
怪しくてこれ結構現実的な話をしてるん
じゃなくて結構マジで
怖いなって思っちゃって普通にはじめしゃ
ちょーのうち海沿いにあるので
津波とか災害が来た時にもなかなか
厳しいポジションニングしてるなと自信と
か津波の災害とかそれなんかミサイル飛ん
できたりだとかそうなった時に
果たしてこの家でもコンクリートででき
てるんで結構強いと思うんですけど本当に
大丈夫なのかとこんな素敵な3億円の豪邸
どうせだったらもっと強化しちゃおうじゃ
ないかということでなんと
[音楽]
核シェルターおきました
皆さん隠したって聞いてピンとくる俺はね
ピンと来てないあのまだ実物見てないん
ですよ
隠してるとは買えるらしいんですよ
隠シェルターを変えるって聞いてなんか
シェルターはどういう意味かっていうと
英語で
避難所っていう意味らしいですねまあその
核ってつくことによってその例えば核
ミサイルが飛んできた時の
放射能とかを防いだりだとかそのバトル中
とかでもかなり強い
避難所が家に設置できたということで家に
隠しれた運び込むのに1日ぐらいかかって
て
めっちゃ大掛かりなことしてた
ちゃんと法的に道路を塞いでなんか
通行止めにしてでっかい大型クレーンとか
でこうなんか動かしたりして一応設定して
たみたいですというわけで僕まだ実物見て
いません早速隠してるたびに行ってみ
ましょう
はいというわけで各シェルターが置いて
ある場所に来ました
置き場所超悩んだんですよなんか地下に
シェルター置かれる方もいたり結構
置く場所こだわる方がたくさん
いらっしゃるらしいんですけども買う人で
私はですね一応車庫というかガレージの中
に隠せると置かせていただきました早速
ご覧いただきましょうこちらです
[音楽]
[拍手]
初めて見た俺も
[音楽]
えっ監視カメラこの
設置をしっかりと責任を持ってやって
くださった方彼にさんざきさんよろしくお
願いします
キキから逃げる場所っていう
かっこいいちょっと見ていきましょうか
ありがとうございます
これが入り口ですねそうですね
監視カメラ
オレンジ色なのかなここは用の階段
ですね
もうちょっとなんか地味なイメージがあっ
たんですよなんか実用的というか
銀色のもうちょっと業務的なものかと思っ
たらなんかもうガンダムの世界とか
ロボットアニメとかで出てくるようなこの
見た目すごいねちょっとぐるっと回ってみ
ましょうかこれが排気口ね
そうですね
1つだけじゃないんですよ
すごいこれバイオハザード
ケミカルエマージェンシーFallout
シェルター
危険な時はこの印よく使われてるけどこれ
から守れるっていう感染
症とかってことでしょバイオテロが起きた
時もここに逃げ込めばいいのかなそうだね
なんかそういう有害物質っていうのかな
ガスとかそういったものからも守れる
すごいじゃんなんかあれがあるんだけど
はしごこれはですね屋外とかに
設置する方ももちろんいるじゃないですか
で例えば雪国とかこういった方だと
雪が積もったりとかするあーなるほどね
そういったメンテナンスとかあとなんか中
にはなんか太陽光とか置く人もいるらしく
て
時間発電できるように天井に
登ってメンテナンスとかできやすいように
はしごがついてるえすごいんですか
[音楽]
おお上は普通になんかでも
綺麗なの全然ワンちゃんものとか起きそう
ですねしっかり電源もついてますねこれ
すごいのがあれなんですよ家庭用の
コンセントで使えちゃうんですよほら
繋がってるじゃん
エアコンついてるの見ちゃったかアイリス
オーヤマのエアコンアイリスオーヤマのね
すごい
ラストシュートついてるのこれ
は
何かあった時ってことそう中から出れるよ
ここからは
放射能とかも通さないってことそうあの
構造説明すると
壁とかに
鉛が入ってるらしくて鉛っていうのは
放射物質とかを通さないような通しにくい
か作りになっててさらに断熱材とかも入っ
てるからボーンとかそういったもう本当に
頑丈な作りになってるらしいです海の近く
だから
津波とか地震とかで何かが崩壊してもこれ
頑丈ってことでしょそう一応ね
災害用ではないというか
津波とか
浮いたりとかしないんだけどがれきとか
やっぱ頑丈な作りやってるからなんか降っ
てきてもこの中に入れば
助かるところが高いと皆さんこれ大事なの
は中ですどうします
刑務所みたいな中だったなんか俺調べたん
だよ
怖くて
核ミサイルが飛んできて
放射能がパーってなった時に23週間
ぐらいは外出ちゃダメなんだって
食ってくるからこの中で少なくとも1週間
以上123週間生活する覚悟はしといた方
がいいよっていうはいなのでなんかすごい
大事です
ちょっと見ていきましょうかえっと本当に
緊急事態の時は
靴とかどうこう言ってられないんですけど
今だけはゆっくり土足を目指してください
本当にやめて駆け込むから多分開けます
これが隠してるよ
やばいでしょ
やばいね
家や待って待って待って出したはい
これ避難所本当に本当になんか外から見る
とシェルターって聞くとやっぱさっき言っ
たようなコンクリートとか
圧迫感があるような内装だと思うんです
けど
くつろげちゃうっていう
[音楽]
かエロくないけどなんかちゃんと生活を
意識してるね
扉でも重いね
頑丈にできてるからね
こうすれば
放射能からも逃げられるとわかったこれ
マジで通さねえよって鉄の衣装を感じる
すごいやっぱ扉はさすがにいかついけど
ちょっとご覧くださいこれ
周りがこれすれば大地君に俺カタログ見せ
られたわ床と壁どれがいいみたいな
カタログ渡されてじゃあなんかラグっぽい
感じ
コンクリートだからちょっと対照的に来て
お願いします」って言ったらこれですか
めっちゃ
身長俺高いけど全然建てる
[音楽]
けどこんだけ広いとねすいませんまだ家具
とか全然置いてないんですよ本当に今到着
したんですけど
机とかを受けるとね
できるねいや出したすごいこれ部屋よ部屋
部屋がねマジで生活できる
こんなになんか
身近なというか多分俺たちが逃げる時って
絶対危機的状況だと思うんですけども
ちょっと気が緩みそうで怖いです
電球がバレないように
接触しないようになってます色々見てみ
ましょうかあこれがさっきやった監視
カメラだ
じゃんこれすごいね
何かあった時にやっぱさっき言った通り
ここに何日もいるわけじゃん外の様子
分かりづらいと確かにねこのカメラを通し
て外の状況を確認するっていう状態が来た
かどうかとかねずっとここいるとわかん
ないけどこれを見れば周りに何が起きてる
かわかるとすごいななんかちゃんとしてる
わマジで
まあでもなんかよく聞くのは自信とかある
時ってミサイルを使ったことがないから
わかんないけど
ネット止まったりするイメージもあるけど
確かに普通に日常的にこの部屋を使えそう
ね逆に日常的に使ってた方が
緊急時に何かが壊れてるとか
故障してるとかないから日々使っておいた
方がひょっとしたらいいのかもしれない
そうだねあとやっぱりあの
災害時って
定年とかしちゃうと
結局外からコンセント取ってるから電気が
遮断されちゃう一番下にすると発電機から
電力
供給するモードになってポータブル電源
そのポータブル電源から電気を供給でき
るっていう
電源からじゃなくてもエアコン入る人もね
暑い時寒い時いつ起きるかわかんないから
マジで冷房つけよ
すごいわこれマジで
脱出します
ここからこうやってさっきの外に行け
るって事ね外からの空気をろ過して
綺麗な空気になって入ってくるようにする
フィルターなんだそれで新鮮な空気を入れ
続けられる
いやマジで各シェルターやんすごい
らしいです
すごいこれはマジでこの家の
価値が大きく上がったと思うこれ何だけ
戻ったどると俺が言い出したんだけどなん
か
隠せるなんでこんなことになったんだ
えっとね
SNS
Twitterかなんかで隠れた写真が
回ったんでかっこいい隠しシェルターが
あるのでそれは多分見て
欲しいって言い出したんだよすごいなぁ
どんぐらいかかったっけ納品まででもなん
か最近多いらしいんですよ
架空シェルター買われる方が本当に5ヶ月
くらいだった
気になることがありましてもうほぼ家を
買ったみたいなもんですよ本当ですよ
そして監視カメラもついているエアコン
汚染された空気を
浄化するフィルター
お高いんじゃないですか
値段何も水大地のこれ買っといてって言っ
たんですけどそれぐらいなんでしょうか
よろしいですかはいお願いしますこちらの
各シェルターずばり
750万円でございます
3億円かかっておかしくなっちゃった全部
高いですよ
高いなそれぐらいなのか本体は600
ぐらいなんですけどそこから色々
搬入する被害であったり
諸々含めて750万なるほどねこれさ何人
ぐらい入れるんかな
俺ちょっと全員は収容できないじゃん
人選が始まる
[音楽]
ぎゅうぎゅうに落ち込んで10人ぐらいの
収容できそうな気がしますちょっとわかん
ない何人入るかただ物とか生活もすること
を考えると
でも
34人とかなんじゃないかなわかんない今
何も置いてないんですけどもこの後
机だったりベッドだったり食料とかも
しっかり置いてね本当に緊急の
避難所としてここは使いたいと思います
すごいね本当にデザイン性がしっかりし
てるで防音なんでしょ
ちゃんとパンフレットもあるんですよ
クライシス01ちょっと見てみようかな
世界の核シェルター普及率日本
めちゃくちゃ低いなんかスイスとか
イスラエルはもう100%なんだって日本
がマジで全然みんな意識してない
パンフレット見たらさほぼ家なんですよ
もう家みたいに使ってるし外観とかも
かなりオプションがあるっぽいですね
デザインとかもかなりこだわれるみたいな
のでもちろん楽しむものではないのかも
しれないけど生活する空間となると
やっぱり居心地の良い場所の方が長くいる
と思うのでこういうこだわりは大事だと
思いますちょっと生活できるように
いろいろ準備はしておきますもっと詳しい
説明とか奥までの過程は大地君の会員
チャンネルでやってるので気になった方は
そこで是非見てみてください以上隠された
赤でした